we start with Tiger Woods because his
personal life dominating the headlines
again with explosive claims from Tiger's
ex that could land them both in court
the new controversy surrounding
Superstar golfer Tiger Woods the golf
Legends former girlfriend Erica Herman
she was the manager at his restaurant in
Florida now she's taking the 15-time
major Champion to court that's tiger
kissing and bear hugging his now ex
after winning the Masters in 2019 cut to
now the 39 year old is suing him for 30
million et's obtained Erica hermann's
lawsuit filed Monday and on the cover
she's claiming sexual abuse which could
invalidate the NDA he had her sign when
they started dating nearly six years ago
by claiming that she's a victim you have
the ability to say that an NDA is not
enforceable what a judge could say
though is unless you have specific
allegations of either sexual harassment
or assault then I'm not going to hear it
her big card that she played was making
it public which she has now essentially
won if you will the first battle Erica
says Tigers quote aggressive use of the
NDA is preventing her from bringing
various legal claims against him this is
Erica's second lawsuit back in October
she accused tiger of causing severe
emotional damage claiming after they
split his agents used trickery to kick
her out of the 48 million dollar Florida
mansion they shared by sending her off
to a vacation only to change the locks
and remove her belongings the former
bartender is asking for the 30 million
citing a verbal agreement that allowed
her to live their rent-free in exchange
for performing valuable services for the
gulf grade there really does not seem as
if she has any leg to stand on it's his
home he has the right to say you're no
longer welcome here Erica is demanding a
jury trial tiger says the claims are
invalid and once things handled
privately what are sources telling us
this behavior is nothing new tiger will
quote cut people off without warning
when he's done with them and go on with
his life our fighter you've defied the
odds every time nearly one year ago
today Erica was right there as Tiger's
daughter Sam spoke in His World Golf
Hall of Fame induction Tiger kissed
Erica grateful that she helped him
through the aftermath of his 2021 car
crash where he nearly lost his leg and
his career just want to say thank you to
Erica I was unfaithful I had affairs I
cheated of course in 2009 Tiger's
cheating scandal also nearly killed his
career and today mistress Rachel yucatal
is weighing in on the NDA he had her
sign claiming to the dailymail.com there
was an abusive nature in getting me to
sign that to keep me quiet and there was
abusiveness in keeping me quiet for 14
years after
[Music]